but I want to thank you so much for
coming here today I want to thank Jared
and Lena Analytics for having me I want
to thank my friend Dan Chen for pushing
me to submit something to this
conference so I'm really excited to be
here my name is Samantha Tanner I'm a
triple AAA Science and Technology Policy
fellow at the Bureau of Labor Statistics
and if you want to know more about this
awesome program please come up and talk
to me about it afterwards it's really
great if you are a PhD when you're
looking to get into government so today
I'm going to be talking about page down
and I have a few disclaimers before I
get started here first of all want to
talk about my background you know I
didn't write this thing that I'm gonna
talk about it's the work of three guys
that are at our studio so I know that
there's some people from I think there's
some people from our studio in the
audience so if I make a mistake please
forgive me
but what basically what I'm going to be
talking about is this thing called page
down and it's this really cool our
package that allows you to write paged
HTML so you can print off paged HTML
document so that it looks like you made
from PDF but it's actually from HTML so
anyways I'm also going to make some
assumptions about you in this talk so
some assumptions you firstly they're not
going to be accurate a hundred percent
of the time so I apologize in advance
for that first I'm gonna assume that
you're at least familiar with latex as a
thing that is used for making PDFs and
what writing things in math and then I'm
going to assume that you're familiar
with an are marked own document that you
know kind of what llamo is kind of what
our markdown is and you know how to make
an hour code chunk and finally I'm going
to assume that you'll at least enjoy
some of my pop-culture references and if
not I apologize for that you know
Millennials right so before I talk about
page John I obviously have to talk about
latex but why would I spend time talking
about latex when I'm trying to talk
about this cool new thing called page
down and it the idea is I got to give
you some background right I have to give
you some background on why we need page
down and I need you to try
to me and I can tell you that I use
latex a lot I loved it
for many many many years until very
recently when our markdown started
becoming a thing and now I use our
markdown pretty much exclusively so
let's start at the beginning so this is
me in 2011 I'm the one with the banks
and this is my ru which is a research
experience for undergraduates I was at
Valparaiso University and this is me
with my friends Mike and Casey and our
advisor al our Pudwill and what we were
doing was we were doing math for fun
over the summer as one does when one is
a giant nerd like us and so this poster
was the culmination of our entire
summers work you know we spent hours and
hours critiquing this thing you know
putting an H space here putting a V
space there you know one one block here
one block there so that was the summer
of late F I totally fell in love with
latex I loved it after that I used it in
all my math homework assignments I used
it in all my graduate school homework
assignments to take notes and classes
everything so I totally fell in love
with it and I even because I am a huge
nerd
I even had a favorite command which is
phantom anybody familiar with this
command latex gives okay a couple people
so this is kind of a crazy command don't
know where it comes from but I
discovered it when I first learned latex
and hence every time I use latex it
might show up open I'm a little bit
better now but so the idea with this
thing is you can add any amount of white
space exactly where you need it
regardless of the template you're using
of any of the fiddly latex rules
whatever is you can just add white space
at random and so sometimes it looked
like this phantom with two little a's in
there just a little bit of space and
then sometimes when i was really
frustrated it looked like this and then
quite often it ended up looking like
this just phantom everywhere and who
knows what space is coming from where in
the poster I showed at the beginning
there were only 16 uses of phantom which
I thought was pretty restrained actually
looking back but dealing with late egg
you know templates it's kind of just an
annoyance really it there
really nice and they're really beautiful
but sort of some of the tricky behaviors
is really more of an annoyance than
anything else but there are some larger
problems that they take and that's what
I'm going to talk about now so first and
foremost communication has fully shifted
almost completely from printed methods
to web-based electronic methods latex is
for printing and hTML is for the web so
we need to switch to something for HTML
again getting tables out of PDF huge
problem for me in my experience
absolutely there are tools that do this
super super well I haven't found one
that does it well consistently all the
time so that's a problem in my opinion
and finally Layton is actually
inefficient so here's this paper from a
few years ago that found that typing a
document in late is actually slower than
typing in in word so this is the
abstract the link is there if you want
to go but what you're seeing here is
that the authors conclude that even
experience like tech users so people
like me and other academics they may
suffer a loss in productivity relative
to other document preparation systems
so there are belt says about this paper
out there but the point is pretty
compelling right we think this latex is
this great awesome tool but it's
actually slower than we think it is um
and I still switch back and forth
occasionally between Lane tech and
markdown to do things markdown does feel
faster to me and although I'm still
fairly anti Microsoft Word I use it
everyday because I worked in the
government now so you know six and one
half a dozen of the other
if that doesn't convince you that latex
is inefficient that it's taking up so
much of your time
consider this space that it's taking up
on your computer the last time I looked
at miktex it was 200 gigabytes for
Windows and 50 gigabytes per mac so
that's a lot of space right so it's
inefficient but that being said latex
does have some obvious benefits first
and foremost it's beautiful at
typesetting and that's what it was made
for it was made for typesetting books
with lots of math and its really it as
excellent at that does that really well
cannot be beat right it's pretty
ubiquitous so in more quantitative
fields especially
you know everybody in academia uses
latex it's inescapable often many
journals do have custom latex templates
and then it can just seem like it's not
worth the trouble to avoid it and also
you kind of get this feeling of
belonging right and there's a belonging
is a link to an article that talks more
about this but when you learn latex and
this has been at least my experience is
that you know you have of this
hieroglyphics on your screen right and
all of a sudden you press this button or
you press a couple buttons on your
computer and voila you get this
beautiful types of document with all
these beautiful mathematical formulas
and you just get this rush of academic
superiority it runs over you right and
so that that feels good right no this is
more of a you know a cult but you know
we're only human and belonging feels
good right so this is an advantage of
latex right it does what it does well
it's pretty much everywhere in some some
circles and you know you feel like you
belong to something okay so now that
we've covered that let's talk about page
down so first we have to about why are
we going to use page on page Don so
hopefully and what what motivates it so
you've been paying attention for the
first this talk despite all the
difficulties but why you're going to use
page Dom well the main reason is that
the web has taken a much faster to share
things over the web right eco friendly
does your think web but printing is not
ever going to go away we're still gonna
have it I mean we still use fax machines
all the time for my purposes right
printing is never gonna wait um so how
do we move these two arenas closer
together and that's the motivation
behind page Don and most people be
pretty intimidated by this research page
down right so they're saying you see
this question can we print a book with
HTML and CSS and these guys say yes we
can another motivation for a page down
is that printing from the web can get
pretty ugly right so you have this
printed off version with all this stuff
on the top scrawled on the bottom and
then you have all these boxes moved all
over
place and it looks nothing like the
beautiful web that you saw and so that
page down is a way to make printing from
the web prettier so that's another
motivation and how are we gonna do this
and in this section I make no claim to
be an expert in understanding things
that are HTML CSS I'm not a web
developer I'm just somebody who really
really really likes our and I like to
use it for everything I've used it to
send emails everything so this page is
is an open source library that is going
to paginate content in the browser so
it's a fairly new thing and it's all
widths yep prose the style behind all
things HTML and then in an HTML page you
can sort of see that these are if you
look at all these boxes those are all
different CSS classes so you can get
it's pretty strict structure but you can
see that you can control each one of
these little boxes here with CSS and
with your in page don't with HTML so how
do we use it this is two lines of code
there are less than ten in this talk so
you just install it from crayon or from
the github repo and for the development
version like any other our package and
then you can use it right away so it's
the easiest way to do it is to go into
our studio just create a new our
markdown file and you pick this each
HTML document that's like the default
that's like your standard our markdown
document for paged HTML and so I got all
things in our markdown a page down
document is going to start with a yamo
header and it contains markdown and code
chunks and that's it you know all you
have to do really the only difference
here between a page down document and
any other are markdown document that you
might be using is just these three lines
of highlighted yellow that's it so
there's also lots of templates you can
if you go if we go back a few slides you
can see there's a poster couple poster
options there's a paper option a few
other options so you can just use the
templates so in my experience the
templates are super friendly you just
edit the Hamill put your own name your
own date whatever
and then you change maybe there's some
lorem ipsum in there somewhere so you
change some of that and you're good to
go
the the really tricky part comes when
there's any sort of customization yes
ice so that does get really and I'm not
a web developer an expert in this area
so do go to the page what is a I'm just
gonna take this off the page on website
is itself a page on document so go see
that again one to render page down one
of the things that you want to do is
[Music]
this is one of the trickiest things so
if you go to use page down just remember
this slide that's really the only thing
you need to know so it needs a web
server to view it so instead of hitting
it and opening it up in Google Chrome
you can't do that you'll see nothing so
instead run this thing in the command
line so what you do is you have your our
markdown document open here I have my CV
that's in page down and then you run
this infinite moon reader thing line of
code in the console then it opens up in
the viewer done that's it and then you
can open it up in Google I do all of
that okay so now we can do some fun
things which are page down examples so
first this is my web CV I like it a lot
I think it's really really pretty I like
it so much more oh I like it so much
more than all of my other than my other
like latex CV which I was like I had
spent hours on this thing making it
beautiful right and this was like 20
minutes just typing things it's really
really nice my favorite part was you can
see these little icons next to
everything that's my favorite part
[Music]
I'm particularly proud of let's see this
one right here for leadership and
service I'm really proud of that one
anyway is that I mean all you do is do
fiddly little things like that and it
just does it all for you so that's
really really nice right that's one of
the major advantages of page town also
you can do business cards so I happen to
make this business card for my partner
he's on the job
here for my new job so he needs a job so
if you know anybody hiring lawyers right
there but this took me all of three
minutes to do in pagedown it's pretty
easy but we have to conclude with some
of the disadvantages of pagedown like I
said you know lay tech is very very
superior in these things
it's very dominant so we do have to talk
about the disadvantages of pagedown so
first of all it's brand new I'm not
gonna sing the song but you know the
song it's not well developed yet this
thing that it's based on the page Jas is
still pretty under development page on
itself is still under development you a
just premiered it at our seochon earlier
this year right and latex has about 40
40 years 50 40 150 years on it so you
know it's a baby a baby sure another
disadvantage of pagedown that it's very
strict so it's very dependent on exactly
precise CSS classes kind of like harsh
with all those little boxes at the on
the page down document and it can be
fiddly with the zoom level so if you're
zoomed in too far things will move
around all sorts of things customization
is really hard so that's what another
problem is with with page down so you
can picture all of your content is a
cute little girl with pigtails and page
down is Miss Trunchbull just launched
her around wherever she feels like it I
actually did try to recreate that poster
that I showed you at the beginning that
was made in latex it didn't work I don't
know if I just didn't set enough time
for it or I was trying to fit you know
this sweat of latex into this beautiful
you know round hole of page down but it
just didn't it just didn't work but you
know templates a very strict that's
another disadvantage of page down you
have to design specifically the poster
you have to design it with the the
patient template in mind and finally
change is hard
people love tech researchers that using
it for years and it does the job people
don't like having to learn
new tools right case in point why does
our iPhone keyboard look like this it's
because many many years ago when we were
doing typewriters all the bars got stuck
together so they had to put them like
this and if you switch to a more
sensible like alphabetical order
keyboard it might be faster but it's
just not worth the hassle to switch so
this is how we do things now it's kind
of the same thing with light deck this
is just how we do things now so I'd like
to conclude here by saying that I still
like latex it's still beautiful it still
does a really good job it is bulky and
it can be inefficient so keep that in
mind but I really hope that you will
start switching to page down because I
really like it it's forward-thinking it
is flawed but it's really a lot of fun
and I hope that you know as we move
forward and markdown becomes more and
more popular and like especially with
reproducibility I think that's really
important so I'll close by saying that
and I try to say thank you so much for
putting up with the technical issues and
thank you and you can see the slides and
find me online thank you so much
[Applause]